the speed of the iraqi forces advance
into western mosul
constantly changes
sometimes it is fast at the moment
it is almost ground to a halt
this is the main road to one of the
bridges that crosses the tigris to the
liberated eastern part of the city
the mud berm is the start of islamic
state territory
the iraqis haven't been able to winkle
out sniper cells
so they've resorted to this
[Applause]
constantly
mortar positions attack day and night
when specific targets are identified
they use these
despite this huge force islamic state
still holds
much of the west and as each day passes
this ancient city
is being reduced to russia
in some conflicts in cities in
particular the areas that are really
quite safe but here
in west mosul absolutely nowhere is safe
at all
front line just up that road front line
is just up that road
that's what it's like here for the
civilians of course they're stuck
in the middle and many of them simply
can't get away
how people have survived all of this
long enough to escape is simply
astounding
in small groups they carry what they can
and walk through the front lines
into the hands of an army that by and
large they're scared of
the intensity of the fighting has left
them with no choice
over the sound of gunfire down the road
a medic
overseeing the evacuation told me that
the people are extremely traumatized
and that they have to get them away from
the city as soon as possible
the operation is basic but so far it's
coping with the numbers
that are able to leave but this is still
very dangerous the buildings in the
distance
are in islamic state west mosul it looks
far away on camera but trust me it is
not
where they've come from is under attack
what's their reaction
as the latest volley of mortars goes in
[Music]
away from the front line conditions
deteriorate quickly
wind swept open ground they're given
food and wait for buses to take them to
tented camps
that will likely be their homes for a
very long time
this is heartbreaking stuff
little children trudge towards their
future with their favorite possessions
mums and dads try to keep their families
together
they can promise their children nothing
anymore
but they did get them out stuart ramsey
sky news
west